hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to for one night only the
game where you play is a little girl
wandering around in the woods usually
it's the other way around your little
girl or you're not the little girl or
the little girl that's trying to scare
the pan how do I even pretend like you
know wait a minute who are you I'm a
figment of your imagination
a manifestation of your fear that
usually ends poorly did you write that
on the wall I don't know how I feel
about listening to Irish ghosts in my
head oh I got the candle tigers bears
acrobats in a clown everybody the circus
is in town
the Ringmaster's mad and full of fun but
have to doc you better run he'll lock
you up in a box so tight until you grow
into an awful sight you'll cry and
scream when you're all lonely you'll be
lucky if you're alive for one night only
yeah okay thank you everybody for
applauding me now now what do I do
so apparently there's some demonic
circus in town and I probably have to
find it but I'm just a little girl alone
in the woods I'm mark a princess little
girl and I'm not supposed to be here
because the dark is scary you can
relight the cable well that's what I
figured but why did you need to tell me
that I may be a little girl but I'm very
smart wander into the dark woods alone
huh that seems like a good idea question
why I'm here there's actually quite a
bit of detail would that a ghost friend
want to call you okay never mind you
went away before I came up with a clever
name to call you so I guess you're not
my friend anymore
I break
hope that wasn't that bird oh hello
again I want to call you big beak berry
cuz you got a big beak and you okay pie
I thought you might have been able to
help okay you got a hold on big beak
berries got big friends okay bye I'm
gonna okay just got it go now
I see little lights in the distance I'm
assuming that I'm supposed to follow
them but wait which way am I supposed to
go eeny meeny miny we go
we're having a B okay okay I don't know
if that was a coincidence whether I just
press that or there's some urgent need
to run now I don't know about that's
gonna happen any minute now I already
know that this game is gonna be starting
off good because already got a sense of
paranoia
mostly because I have no idea what's
happening in here but also because
there's actually a lot of depths and
ambiance to it i hear critters in the
night I don't think I need to stop oh I
get it I get it
dark equals bad fire equals good I'm a
little girl but I think I might need to
light this entire forest on fire because
maybe that'll be a problem
wait a minute what's this before I start
going insane oh I get it
I'm the precursor to being that
terrifying little girl in the woods
I am the nightmare in the night oh oh is
this a circus does that where they keep
all the aminals the door someone's
working out a Royal Flush but it doesn't
seem to be helping me at all so so hello
you sound familiar
hello nobody in that thing why are you
trying to be doing nothing to me
oh by the way today I just did a wolf
yesterday but whatever I just did shut
up and trying to tell sorry I just did a
video with Bart Baker for a music oh
just my time I can't do anything right
check it out oh okay Oh what are you are
you still there
oh my tongue hurts I'm tired of all the
story is he still there still there
Oh what the hell is that
why is our clown of a face that isn't
bright is that the clown or is what why
do I see them they're just gonna go away
hi mr. clown is that gonna be a constant
pervasive thing I suppose guys so as I
find a key but I also need more candles
juice
I need more fire juice urn down this
decrepit place of me stop that that's
somehow still startling even though I
know it's gonna be happening okay
foosh okay so I just got a runaway from
douche irmak clowny and then I'm
gonna go along my way and never have to
meet him ever gotten now it sounds like
what did you say
What did he say your Irish bastard your
Irishman you would give whatever I think
jacksepticeye is narrating this I'm not
too mistaken he's the only Irishman that
I really knows I'm gonna zoom anytime I
hear an Irish or Scottish voice I assume
it's him what is this place
was it a good idea to go in there
probably not but I don't see a key in
here oh no I don't know I know if I'm
the key I got it stop with the clown I
am in a bit of a predicament I get it
Jack shut up I'm just a little girl or
I'm a grown man but you get the point
supposed to be back home
hello nope no just your most smartest
Tiger I've ever seen in my life
what the clown face mum mammy mammy how
much it bear when I need you usually do
closed forever
oh no what's he gonna do Oh Greg at the
end there oh I see something oh I see
something who is that the key I think I
found the key you don't need to see
nothing about me I got the key and now I
don't need ya hey is that good for me
do I get to go down with me the entrance
though I'm sure nothing bad will happen
to me a little girl last alone when a
clown wants to be in a cage with me okay
so this reminds me of slender carnival
but I wasn't able to beat that game so
it doesn't so what is the cannon cannon
oh that is a nice can and maybe I need
to shoot the clown out of it
what got a little girl would be able to
find all those ingredients though oh boy
you want me to go into them huh
how would a little girl even be able to
carry a damn cannonball know what no
please
huh pick up get here you can't hear
you're menacing threats Oh phantom well
that's good
found that where's the rest of the crap
that I need right very lucky that I
found that oh good good good at all oh
okay oh oh hi okay find the way out so I
got the fuse now I need the Cannonball
and gunpowder or kinda fine though
no there I'm not running I'm Reverend
ray Marie take it office they're gonna
law office dang it all of us don't put
me in no box what what I need you me how
do i yeah I got it I got the candy ball
now I just need the gun powder whoever I
am I'm gonna find that man this is one
beefy little girl carrying a cannon ball
and a fuse
[Music]
oh no doc you like your stupid little
girl what what are you talking about did
you just call me stupid how dare you
I'll have you know I graduated top of my
class in dumb college one give me that
other clown thing is gonna get me never
find a fire air is it fair no I just got
back keep it back a big boo-boo I got a
ball but the boot so I can fire the son
of a oh that was good glad I turn
that on I don't know I don't know what
I'm looking for what I'm looking for a
cannon so let's start we want cannon dun
dun dun dun dun don't please murder me
dun dun dun
hi mommy done no pears I must pass it by
like 10 times turn on the light I
probably walked right passes you go
Lebowski boost the cannonball into the
door and hopefully I'll be scot-free now
I can go home now right I survived the
clown attack I did it I'm the best Thank
You jury and mere low it was a good game
and a lot of solid mechanics there could
have been a little bit more polish on
some of the sequences there it didn't
feel like it was always engaging the
music was quite quiet if you know what I
mean but either way it was still a lot
of fun had some interesting stuff going
on there and the dynamic between doing
the not light and light was actually
well implemented I am actually very
impressed by that I wish there was a bit
more fleshed out but either way it was
still a lot of fun if you guys want to
play this also check out
whatever the hell other clown game I
played I can't even remember the name of
it but it was a really fun one had a
clown in it that's the only tangentially
related thing to it be view a this is a
lot of fun thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]